let's go next to our caller from the 6-5
zero area code who's calling today from
six five zero uh hello that is you yeah
who is this all right so I'm Luke I'm
from the Bay Area
it was Obispo Bay Area standards I'm a
bit of a moderate but I'm just gonna
grant so many things I'm pretty
progressive all right and so um my
question is about like the feasibility
of the progressive plans long term I got
senior videos about like how you know
it's a Sanders administration would like
pay for the things like Medicare for all
I'm the green New Deal and stuff like
that okay but I think don't we ask like
take into account like the American
politics when we were thinking about
these policies so it's like Bernie is I
would say like pretty far on the left of
the mainstream of American politics on
what is so um I worry that
hold on Luke let's explore that on what
issue is Bernie very far to the left
compared to the American population no
not not population politics I can how
politics is going so you're saying so I
just went on you're saying compared to
our the elected officials in the house
and said Bernie's to the left yeah okay
yeah I would grant that that I would say
you're right that the the public at
large is well to the left of the average
of our oh yeah yeah yeah okay go ahead
yeah and so as but like that's so kind
of worrying to me because like say like
you know Bernie gets in and I'd creates
like some great progressive policies and
you know has ways to pay for it but
let's say like a few years down the line
there's a Republican that gets elected
and because like it's very hard to go
back federal spending from previous
administrations and he or she is unable
to do that I'm talking other Republicans
right and they just come up with tax
cuts because that's politically popular
and that seems to avoid some politically
popular and so then we continue to this
trend of where some Democrat gets in and
you know kind of creates a change of
progressive policies and increases
spending and then Republican just come
in don't have a ways of a decreasing
spending but they did like they cut
taxes they cut revenue and then they
scare of programs well yeah I would
challenge you on the idea that the
you said this is this continues the
trend of progressives getting in and
doing progressive stuff and then
Republicans come in and then they cut
revenue what progressives have done what
progressive stuff
well like I mean it doesn't even
necessarily have to be a super
progressive which I guess is one of the
things I'm worried about like I'm I know
that like Obama I could have been a lot
more progressive but like he's still
increased spending like you know with
like the stimulus package and stuff and
okay yeah but I mean I think what you
have to so stimulus package is a
one-time expense number one so that
would be you're talking about how once
you grow the budget it's hard to cut it
back down and I agree with you but then
now you're giving an example of
something that was a a one-time stimulus
or they did you know yeah it was broken
up into a couple of different things I
think that what you're maybe not
accounting for here is that they're
these are programs by and large which
are widely supported by the American
public so imagine for a second Bernie
Sanders becomes president he gets
Medicare for all passed it's paid for
through the payroll tax that he is
proposed but on the back end
employers are no longer paying health
insurance premiums to insurance
companies co-pays go away all of this
different stuff okay more or less we're
just replacing spending with wood
spending from elsewhere if a Republican
president comes in after four years of
that or eight years of that and says hey
we're cutting taxes and what we're going
to stop paying for is that Medicare for
all the backlash would be insane much
the way that it's been insane even
trying to repeal Obamacare which they
haven't been able to do after dozens and
dozens of attempts so I think that your
your concern it's not a it's not a crazy
concern it's just not in practice the
way this would be played out and it
would be a terrible reason not to do
progressive things because a Republican
at some point in the future might try to
cut the funding for it yeah yeah I'd
agree with that it was just yeah thank
you thank you for taking my call and
yeah I really appreciate you and your
show thank you so much really appreciate
the phone call great to hear from Luke
from the bay area good to hear from you
one of today's sponsors is impeach the
card slap game you can't
slap Donald Trump in real life but you
can slap him in this hilarious
fast-paced two-player card game and you
can get it for 10% off when you go to
david pakman.com slash impeach impeach
the card game is awesome for parties or
when you're having a few drinks I've
been playing it with some friends of
mine it combines clever satire about the
Trump administration with really funny
high-quality cartoon artwork all in a
very lively card game that's easy to
learn but it stays interesting every
time you play it because of how well
designed it is and how much thought went
into the humor and the political
commentary impeach the cards slap game
is perfect if you're looking for
something fun and casual to do with your
politically minded friends or family
members it'll make a perfect gift for
anyone you know who has a sense of humor
about Donald Trump don't forget that
Father's Day is coming up and when you
go to david pakman.com slash impeach not
only will you get 10% off the game you
can also get 10% off all of the other
hilarious clothing and accessories in
their online store t-shirts coffee mugs
tote bags featuring funny political
cartoons about trump that you can't find
anywhere else get a super fun
witty gift for yourself or someone you
know whether it's impeach the cards slap
game or anything else in the gift shop
and get 10% off all of it when you go to
david pakman.com slash impeach